After That 70s Show was being a voice on
the Family Guy Oh no I got that during
70s I was 15 I couldn't yeah I was 15
years old at they needed a voice for the
character met Griffin I guess was the
they had someone and she quit yeah I
know why why would you quit a gig like
that because you just didn't think it
out I just I can't I'm so grateful that
this woman was like this is not for me
right because this is the greatest gig
in the whole world I mean if you think
about it from a career standpoint it it
it's great money right I mean aming and
you go in what for a day and do you work
with the other voice actors on that show
no is Seth McFarland he's not even there
anymore he doesn't he doesn't show up at
first and teach you how to do the voice
and all that in the beginning like for
years he was always there and I think
just as the show went on and as
everybody kind of found their own
footing we all just show up at our own
time on like a Thursday and and which is
great you get to know him and then he
puts you in the movie Ted right yes yeah
was that fun to do Ted yeah Ted was an
amazing project because I wasn't
supposed to be in Ted right Ted was
something that he wrote
years before I got involved and I was
too young to do it and it had all these
other actors and he would always just
come up to be like who do you what do
you think about this girl what do you
think about this SCH and I would always
give like my five cents and whatever
actress he was looking into cuz I was
too young right and then like he it
would be a different lead before it was
wallberg it was so many other guys 5
years later I became of the proper age
and he was like why don't you do it and
I was like oh yeah I guess I could and
that's how literally how it happened did
you think that movie was going to be as
big a hit as it was no cuz it's crazy
sounding right a talking teddy bear who
is dirty and it's an R-rated thing and
it's how are little kid's going to go is
it for adults nothing about it was like
logical so I was like this is going to
be great nothing about Family Guy made
sense either but do you do it because
it's Seth McFarland or you do it because
also Mark Wahlberg's involved in it no
because wallberg and I had already work
together he and I did Max pain together
and he and I did date night together so
I I love W I like I love Mark I think
he's a great guy I did it because Seth
was a friend of mine you know isn't it
funny how that works too I always assume
like if you work on a movie with a guy
like Mark Wahlberg that instantly you
guys would become lovers and then
boyfriend and girlfriend or something I
always think that no like no it never
just evolves into that no we're very
good at just working together yeah
that's amazing to me I guess I'm so
horny and and and gross that I just
think happen for you on I'm like oh my
God he I'm G to be in a movie with and
she's going to be my
girlas